welcome everyone this is building you
eyes in the dark
I'm Richard Feldman this is my first
time in Sweden and so far I've learned a
couple things one is the saunas are very
warm very nice two is the Baltic Sea is
very cold in November so I'd recommend
the first thing not sure about the
second thing all right so let's imagine
that you sit down at your computer your
laptop you have your hands over your
keys and this is what you see nothing
just pitch blackness so this is what
programming is like for this particular
programmer if you look at his desk here
you might notice that there's a keyboard
and and there's headphones standard
programming equipment there's something
missing that that you and I might be
used to there's no monitor there's no
display and this is because this
particular developer is blind and he
wrote this blog post absolutely
fascinating I highly recommend reading
it on his company's blog called software
development at 450 words per minute and
he explains how he programs and
basically what he hears in those
headphones is text-to-speech reading
code to him really really fast
I'm gonna do my impersonation of this I
mean you have no idea if you listen to
it it just sounds like absolute
gibberish it's like I don't know how he
has learned to to listen to this this
fast but he's actually productive doing
this and and you know if you imagine
like what does flow state like for him
that's different from flow state for us
flow state when you really get in the
zone you're just kind of letting the
code flow through you this is this is
gotta be a completely different
experience and yet he also gets into
flow state same ways we do this really
fascinated me he said I've had my fair
share of angular and react work if
you're not a front-end developer these
are front-end programming technologies
for the web so he's doing UI development
blind and you might think like what how
I mean its UI work how could you
possibly do that like completely in the
dark like this and it turns out that is
like well you know many web apps today
have a lot going on under the hood it's
not all layout and visual stuff there's
actually quite a lot of business logic
that lives in the client of a web
application now and this actually didn't
always used to be the case like back in
the days before web apps
what some might call the good old days
we used to have basically just static
HTML only it was all content that was it
no interactivity really not not on the
client-side
I mean JavaScript existed it was like
too slow for more than just like making
stuff follow your mouse around for some
reason and really people were on like
dial-up connections at best like 56k was
like yeah that's a good modem right
there so the idea of making a web app
back then it was just kind of a
non-starter
so the beginnings of web apps really
were sort of like still rendering HTML
but it was sort of doing it dynamically
on the fly on the server and I kind of
sort of oh hey we can actually do this
in the JavaScript god fast that's like
we can do more with JavaScript and
bandwidth got increased and we started
to see more and more broadband and this
sort of led to the rise of web apps you
know we started to see really rich web
applications things like the idea of a
map application in the browser with no
flash I mean back in the 90s that would
have been completely absurd but now
we're just like oh yeah that's you know
I do that my phone right running on
smart phones which didn't even exist
back in the early days the development
ecosystem is really mature it's come a
long way for building client-side web
applications and servers have gotten a
lot cheaper and of course as you might
imagine this is sort of changed the
nature of what front end code looks like
I guess especially as a percentage of
code based over time like it's just
absolutely taken off I mean the amount
of front-end code that we write today
relative to how much we did back in the
days when everything was on the server
is just skyrocketed and we've even
gotten to the point where people are
talking about things like event sourcing
actually I've done this at work in some
cases maybe behind my lips event
sourcing is you basically log user
actions like user clicks on a thing you
essentially just send that straight to
the server and the server doesn't really
do anything it just writes it down in a
database and then you can sort of replay
those events later on to restore the
user state at this point you're
basically saying all of the logic is on
the front end the server is not doing
anything it's just spinning stuff
straight into a database and then
spitting it back out to the front end
which takes care of restoring the state
completely and managing everything now
the complexity of front-end has also
been affected by this as you might
imagine as the percentage of the
codebase goes up and that's also been
actually no it's been more than that
it's just been straight up its absolute
I mean it's it's completely absurd how
complicated front-end code base
have gotten and so we've you know
there's this natural question that comes
with this like how do we deal with all
this complexity well one answer is what
I've done at work at this company I work
for no red ink we used to be using react
and now we've been using this technology
called Elm so if you're not familiar
with Elm elem is a functional
programming language that compiles to
JavaScript and we've been using it to
help us manage our complexity problems
it's got its own semantics it's it's not
actually JavaScript under the hood it's
not even a JavaScript dialect it has
absolutely nothing to do with JavaScript
except for the fact that it compiles to
it so we can use it on the client lots
of companies using Elm all sorts of
different sizes the ones on the left you
may be familiar with the ones in the
middle may be less likely to be familiar
with it was alright even less likely
because they're sort of smaller
companies so big little and small it
works for all shapes and sizes
and one of the things that people have
been asking for quite some time was hey
yeah is there any sort of single page
application example so I can see what an
SP a looks like an elm and for awhile
there wasn't one because people will say
well yes we've got plenty of them
they're all proprietary you can't see
them so people are asking for an open
source one and I found out about this
project called real world and it's
pretty cool the basic idea behind real
world is they have a specification for a
clients as well as a server and so you
can implement it using different
technologies you can use react Elm
angular for the front end whatever you
want also on the back end you can use
Django or laravel or whatever you know
back in technology you want so you can
see this sort of like mix and match of
these different technologies and it's a
it's a pretty sizable single page app
example it's it's got sort of like a
medium clone although they called it
conduit instead of medium conduit medium
okay and the basic idea is you've got
you know enough functionality to sort of
demonstrate what a single-page app might
look like in each of these different
technologies so you got stuff like you
can write posts you can view a feed you
can look at tags you can edit your
settings log in log out sign in sign up
all that good stuff so here's a if you
want to take a look at this particular
one later that's the URL so um a couple
years ago I was on this flight where I
was working on this and you know if
you're like me you think four hour
flight and you're like that's not a
flight that's a for our coding party yes
there's gonna be no distractions I can't
check Twitter you know there's no Wi-Fi
that's a fee
if the plane doesn't have Wi-Fi oh it's
like that's $20 I can't afford $20 so
I'm gonna have no choice but to focus on
one thing for the whole time which will
be great so I was really excited about
this line yes I'm gonna work on this
thing and that that happened to be the
project I was working on so I was really
looking forward to this until I realize
there's a slight problem which is that
if you're offline and every single page
load begins with an HTTP request to a
third-party service that I don't control
and isn't on my laptop that means I
can't use the browser for any of this
for our coding session which if you're
doing UI development is usually a bit of
a hindrance this is sort of the problem
I was faced with and I was like ah there
goes my coding party I was like okay
well I don't know I'll just like write
some code and I'll see how far I can get
and it turns out four hours later I the
planes landing and and I have Wi-Fi
again and it's like yeah I was just
coding the entire time as it turns out I
I was able to be productive for the
entire four hours writing elm code and
when I landed and got the Wi-Fi back
everything that I had built worked on
the first try when I had Wi-Fi again now
when I tell people this story I get two
different reactions commonly if the
person I'm talking to is used on before
they're like yeah I know what you're
talking about
I know I've been there right that's
that's good stuff and that's the person
does not use them before they're like I
don't believe you that's not that's not
a true story that could not have
happened because it's it's kind of
impossible right I mean front-end
development right we're talking about
building UIs again it's it's it's
implausible you could do front-end work
for four hours no internet connection
not be able to use the browser and still
be productive so I thought you know what
better way to demonstrate what I'm
talking about then to do it live on
stage so let's actually add a feature to
this without opening the browser so
you're gonna sort of see get a feel for
at least a small taste of what type of
stuff I was doing on this flight so here
we see on the Left this is sort of the
the my articles tab on your feed so you
can click my articles and see a list of
all the articles that you've written
here's a article that I've theoretically
written that just says hello to everyone
and you can see this another tab over
there called favorited articles and when
you click favorited articles it shows
you other people's articles that you've
clicked favorited on so we're gonna do
is we're going to add that feature the
the favorited articles features so I've
got a build where I've sort of taken
that out and we're just gonna go through
adding it right here in the editor live
alright okay now the first rule of doing
live coding is that you make sure that
you have everything in your cache right
so like you never want to do like RM RF
the equivalent of like LM stuff which is
like the equivalent of node modules you
never want to interesting alright um
well let's just see you know maybe I can
run this build and maybe it won't take
too long do those fast okay so one thing
to note about Elm it's really fast and
it's also really good at caching stuff
so um all the like downloaded modules
and stuff I have there just happened to
be in my local cache already anyway so
when I'm building from scratch even if I
have you know my project specific cache
deleted that's no big deal it can
rebuild it very quickly
okay so we have right here I'm not gonna
talk too much about what this code is
doing while I'm live coding it because I
have slides that are sort of explaining
in more depth so I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna first go through this and kind of
show you the process and then we're
gonna talk through in more depth in the
slide and kind of explain what I've been
doing okay so we have this function
called view tabs we have right here my
articles so that corresponds to the one
that we've already got what we're gonna
do is we're gonna add favorited articles
I already have that my clipboard so I
have to type it out so it's gonna hit
save and now I'm gonna rebuild by the
way I'm gonna throw a QuickTime on this
build and we're gonna see that it was
able to give me an error message in
point two two six seconds so that was
pretty quick so that's that's a pretty
quick feedback loop there before I know
what I need to do next
it says naming error I cannot find a
favorited articles constructor you can
see it's it's underlined up here in my
editor so I have you know editor tooling
that's gonna give me the full error I'm
doing it down here in the console so you
can sort of see the the raw thing if you
were just running it from the CLI can I
find it favorited articles constructor
these names even close though okay well
it's telling me that I don't have one of
those because it doesn't exist I just
made it up and all I'm gonna do through
this
time is just follow the errors that I
get from having added this new thing and
sort of pretending that favorited
articles is already a concept that
exists the first thing I'm gonna do is
I'm going to say okay
so favorited articles I happen to know
that's going to be one of my feed types
currently I only have one of those
defined which is my article so I'm just
gonna right click hit go to definition
and say okay I need to add some feed
articles right here alright our
favorited articles rather favorited
articles okay great
so we've got that added now let's
rebuild see what happens okay once again
0.2 to 2 seconds we have our next feed
back missing patterns by the way this is
about 4,000 lines of code so these are
these are not compiling you know hello
world exactly this case does not have
branches for all possibilities so okay
and then we have a second arrow down
here which is another missing patterns
this other case does not have branches
for all possibilities
so you see the line number here on the
Left 116 so I'm gonna hop over there and
again if I were just doing all this in
my editor I would probably just be
hitting next error but I'm gonna do it
with the the console just to show that
okay now I happen to know that the way
that I'm gonna solve this is I'm gonna
add another branch here instead of my
articles it's gonna be favorited
articles and I know that the only thing
I'm gonna change here this is gonna be
the part that actually goes and does the
HTTP request instead of going to the
author URL I'm going to go to the
favorites URL okay notice when I hit
save by the way the the whitespace
changed a little bit I'm using Elm
format on save and Elm format as a cool
thing that basically formats your code
so whenever I save it just makes it look
nice this is a feature that pretty much
everybody I know who uses Elm uses and
one of the cool things about it is that
it has no configuration which means your
team can't argue about it there's only
one way to use it which is you just run
it it's really nice okay so that let's
see if that fixed one of our errors sure
enough it did we're now down to one
missing patterns err its line 287 okay
and we see we're back down here I'm
gonna create a little bit of code
duplication then when we get to the
slides I'm gonna resolve it so my
article is gonna change that to
favorited articles and I happen to know
that basically what this is doing right
here is it's showing which of these two
tabs is selected versus not and I'm
gonna shuffle yous around a little bit
because I want my articles to be not
selected and I want favorite articles to
be selected the selected one select the
one goes in the middle
okay so now I have fixed that and now
boom successful compile and it
successfully compiled it and generated
all of the code the output in point
three seconds now this is an incremental
build so we know that this is now safe
so I've guess I've kind of spoiled that
but I can RM my local cache and build it
again completely from scratch and that
brings it all all the way up to one
second so that's a complete scratch
build incremental obviously is much
faster than that so you can imagine if
this were a much bigger than 4,000 line
of code code base this is still quite a
nice feedback loop to have and in fact
when I was pure programming with one of
my co-workers a while ago we're going
back and forth of doing this and just
kind of be like oh error fix it error
fix it error fix it and sort of like
going through the code base and you know
working out the implications of the
change we made and we finally went back
to the browser and hit refresh and
actually like used it he looks at me is
like this is so slow waiting for the
browser to load like that takes like way
more than a second Wow oh how did I ever
live like this like yes it's pretty cool
it's actually this is faster it turns
out a faster way to do UI development
okay so as promised now let's actually
go through that a little bit more depth
and kind of talk through what these
things are doing okay so so initially
the goal was just add a new feed a new
tab a favorited articles feed so we had
this code initially this is a sort of
feed beaut abs and it's got three
arguments here and basically the the
square brackets are a list and then the
the parentheses are a tuple it's like
two pieces of information so basically
what we're saying here is we have no
selected tabs to the left of the
selected tab selected tab goes in the
middle and then we have a list of
additional tabs there are no selected
tab unselected tabs after it so what I
did was I added an unselected tab after
it so my articles are selected and then
we have an unselected one after it
and that was where we got our first
error and squiggly underlined indicating
hey this is not a thing you have not
actually created that yet and
specifically it's a naming error I
cannot find a favorited articles
constructor and it underlined it as well
in the CLI but you know the editor is a
little bit nicer and so now we know from
this error hey you know what our next
step is uh we need to actually define
this thing we need to create a thing so
that we're not gonna get this error so
the next thing we did is I did
Oh definition is that okay I wanted to
find a new type of feed tab so we have
one called my articles I'm gonna make a
new one called favorited articles and as
soon as I did that I said hey missing
patterns this case does not have
branches for all possibilities so we had
a case in which I was using my articles
and it's saying okay anytime you have a
case a case is a form of conditional and
whenever you're doing a case on one of
these things these custom types it makes
makes you sort of not forget to handle
all the different possibilities
so because we introduced a new
possibility in addition to my articles
we said yeah now there's a new thing
called feed articles it says okay this
I'm glad that you introduced that but
over here I have this conditional that
only has some of the possibilities
specified you need to specify all of
them you need to tell me what to do if I
get one of those values in here okay
yeah fair enough
then it also tells me oh by the way the
missing possibilities include favorited
articles that's the one that I'm missing
like okay cool and it's six really goes
on to explain I would have to crash if I
saw one of those because I don't know
how to handle it as we'll see later elms
really big on not crashing this is okay
so like just add some branches for them
so this is my compiler error and I'm
like okay what's my next step
oh yeah I'd branch this fit so sure
enough that's the next thing I did said
okay and add a favorite articles branch
to this case and that looks like this I
previously mentioned I happen to know
that this is the one that works on the
end point so it's not just you know
mechanical just do exactly what the
compiler says I do have to still have
some knowledge of the system but when I
was on this plane flight I mean I did
know I have knowledge of the system so I
knew what to do in this case which is to
say okay I've specified the HTTP request
that this feed is going to use when it's
loading the data in the first case it's
like oh go get the author endpoint and
here I'm like okay I need to get the the
favourited endpoint instead now this is
logic that I was not allowed to forget
to implement I still have to know how to
implement it but the important part was
that the compiler said yeah you need to
put some logic here I don't know what it
is but I know that there's some logic
that goes here there was no way I could
forget to add that and this is the only
difference between the two finally we
had the last missing patterns error and
you know at this point you can sort of
see a little bit get a little bit of a
taste of like the pattern of doing elm
development once you see enough of these
errors they sort of start to break down
to the pattern so like I kind of know
the shape of a missing
error like okay I see missing pattern so
I know that means I forgot to add
something somewhere I'm gonna jump down
to the yellow highlighted thing can be
like okay that's the thing that I need
to add and then I just know that like
the the remedy here is I need to add
branches so I get pretty fast at these
things so the way that I did that in
this case I said okay I need to add a
branch of favorite articles also to the
view tabs function so this is the part
where it's actually showing which one's
selected and which ones not and
initially we did this using code
duplication just copy pasted it and and
just rearrange them just shuffle them
around because I wanted the favorited
articles wanted to be selected and this
of course is some code duplication so
the way we could resolve this is to
extract those two common pieces of logic
out into top level values and name them
so here's what that looks like
so I basically say okay my articles is
gonna be the one that has the string my
articles and then here's what it does
when you click on it
here's favorited articles which has a
different string and does that when you
click on it and now we can see a little
bit more easily how these sort of
correspond to what ended up actually
happening in the UI so we had my
articles on the Left favorited articles
on the right that's true in both of
these you notice that in both function
calls we have my articles coming first
and favorite articles coming after it
the only difference is in how they're
arranged so in this one we said there's
nothing to the left of my articles
that's unselected and the unselected
stuff to the right of it is favorited
articles with the middle one being
selected and then here we just had the
same number of arguments but they're in
a different order so my articles is
unselected favorite articles is selected
and there's nothing unselected after it
okay so for our flight lands I've just
done the same kind of stuff that we did
there open the browser and it all worked
awesome okay so not every feature gets
this much help to be fair I mean like
this was a pretty straightforward
feature to implement I could just make
one change they pretend that this thing
exists and then just follow all the
implications such that it would it would
go through and it would all work not
every feature gets quite that much help
granted but surprisingly many of them
actually do it's actually a very common
experience to get that much help that
sort of level of compilers support for
what you're working on and the reason
for this is that modifying existing code
like we did here is like pretty much the
type of stuff that we do
all the time this is what I did on the
flight and this is what I do at work
it's what we spend most of our careers
doing this stuff modifying existing code
I know that like most tutorials are
usually like hey let's build this thing
from scratch but that's really like not
the type of programming we typically do
and part of the my motivation for giving
this talk is because if you're doing an
LM tutorial and you're you're you know
working on it from scratch it's kind of
hard to see that like you can't really
see the benefit of like what happens
when you have a more substantial
codebase to the point where I had a
co-worker who you know his first
experience using Elm was on our like
quarter million lines of elm that we
have at work and then he went to a
meet-up later and he was like teaching
some new people Elm and he was like it's
really hard to explain how awesome this
is at work like from this tutorial it's
just this it's not there like the stuff
that's cool about this isn't visible at
small-scale I was like yeah that's a
good point so here we are but adding
features you know refactoring fixing
bugs to an existing code base that's
that's pretty much most of what it means
to be a career programmer so at no red
ink the sort of our journey to get to
where we have gotten we started off back
in 2015 we had a pretty substantial
react codebase and we introduced a
little bit of elm and then you know it
sort of grew 2016 like a sort of
overtook react in our code base and then
it got bigger and now we're basically
we're an elm shop I mean to do front-end
programming at no red ink means you're
you're basically writing Elm all day by
the way that sounds cool we're hiring
and so so an interesting thing that
we've noticed is that our elm code
doesn't really do a certain thing that
we got very used to in JavaScript and so
just give you a little bit of context we
have about five billion questions
answered we make an application for
English teachers to help them teach
students writing we got about a quarter
million lines of elam code at this point
we've been running in production since
2015 about three and a half years and we
use rollbar to track errors like our
runtime exception so whenever something
crashes in the front end we get a roll
bar notification about it so this gives
us a lot of insight into you know where
the sources of our crashes are so here's
a graph of our total production runtime
exception so we had about 60,000 in
JavaScript since 2015 now I apologize I
didn't have enough screen real estate
here it's not actually zero on the Elm
side of zero pixels it did happen we we
did something really
and it happened and we were very sad has
happened last year before I used to get
to say we had zero runtime exceptions
although weirdly people didn't believe
me Ellen people were like oh yeah of
course
but then everybody else is like now
you're logging set up wrong but now that
happened people like whoa you've only
had like that like it's almost never
happened that's incredible yeah for real
I mean that's like it's not it hasn't
been literally zero but I mean it's not
something we think about anymore we just
kind of assumed that our front end code
will never crash and that assumption
never burns us and I've never had that
anywhere I've ever worked I mean I've
been doing this for quite a while that's
never been true in any programming
language I've ever used in any
environment all right I mean it's it's
uh it's unusual and so you might say
like okay well what about like null
pointer exceptions like surely at least
you get NPEs right that's like part of
programming you can't not get NPS but I
mean as you saw we saw some examples in
this live coding of like cases of the
compiler just makes it impossible for me
to forget things right the missing
patterns error like that that was
basically saying hey you defined a new
thing you need to handle that everywhere
it wouldn't let me forget that and so
here's an example of how Elm sort of
handles like null pointer errors and and
makes them impossible for me to forget
handling them so if I wrote this code in
JavaScript I wrote like an array with 1
2 & 3 and I said bracket 0 it's gonna
say okay yeah sure hey go that's gonna
give you back the number 1 and if I did
an empty array and said bracket 0 it's
gonna give me back undefined or if I
were in Ruby would give me back nil
various languages do this in different
ways but pretty much all of them either
give me back some sort of equivalent of
null or like in Python and give me a
runtime exception
now what Elm does is a little bit
different so LM uses that same case
expression which we saw earlier is
subject to missing patterns and in elm
you say case list dot head and then the
name of your list of and then you have
two branches nothing or just and as we
saw if you leave off either of those
branches it's not gonna compile it's
gonna say missing patterns hey you
forgot one of those two possibilities
and this is just how you do these things
in elm like anytime you have something
that's done with null or nil or
undefined in some other language Elmas
gonna do it with these types of patterns
as we saw
not possible to forget that so how would
you possibly get to a crashing case here
you just can't it wouldn't compile and
this is sort of the the key here this is
how Elm gets away with not having null
or undefined or nil it just has
different constructs and as it happens
in a very happy coincidence those
different constructs don't lead to
runtime crashes they just bleed to
compile time errors at worst and LM
api's are all like this the whole
programming language there is no null
there's no undefined in the language
it's this all the way down the core
libraries and everything that's built on
top of them is like this so this is sort
of how Elm gets away with saying hey we
don't have runtime exceptions because
there's really not a thing there's no
try-catch and elm because what would you
even do with that you know I mean it's
it's it's like yes it's conceivably
possible you can still get a stack
overflow you can run out of memory I
mean there are some cases where you know
a crash is possible but they're so rare
they're just like not even worth talking
about and they're just not something
that Ellen programmers do talk about so
this gets to this idea of like what if
your compiler we're not just like
something that sort of were a gatekeeper
what if it was actually an assistant
like what if it was actually assisting
you in writing code and helping you say
like hey you forgot this you forgot this
you forgot that and not just saying no
you're wrong try again I think as we saw
in the live coding demo I was getting a
lot more help than that it wasn't just
me saying oh wait a minute all right
what did I do wrong it was like telling
me the next step to go to every step of
the way it was like hey here's what to
do next here's what to do next
assistant so another example of this is
like when you make typos like you make a
mistake like it said hey model does not
have a field named profile it's not just
gonna say like so figure that out it's
gonna say like hey the type of model is
this so you can go look up your type
definition of model and it says that
doesn't have a field named profile maybe
you made a typo and in fact they're in
your type definition it's like oh
profile oh I see what happened
right it's telling me as much context as
it can possibly give me about this thing
and this is something elms known for us
like really helpful compiler errors that
are not just like well formatted they're
not just you know giving you the bare
minimum of information they're like
trying to actually assist you I'm
particularly fond of this one it's like
a little ASCII art if you have circular
dependencies it's like hey you may need
to remove some of these things remove
them around because right now this
depends on this which depends
this which depends on this and that
forms a cycle it's not gonna work out
for you this one I should have taken a
proper screenshot of this but
unfortunately I just reused it from the
tweet that I saw which was arguably not
the best choice but basically says this
type alias is recursive forming an
infinite type so a type alias is
basically a way of saying I want to just
give a name to this type that I've
already got does what I expand a
recursive type alias it just keeps
getting bigger and bigger so d aliasing
results in an infinitely large type try
this instead and it actually gives you
like hey here's some code that will
actually compile says this is kind of a
subtle distinction I suggested the naive
fix but you can often do something a bit
nicer so I'd recommend reading more at
this link this is like a thing like the
home compiler kind of has a personality
a helpful personality and the tweet that
I copied this from is that should be an
inspiration for every error message and
this was said by a fellow you may know
named John Carmack who's seen quite a
few error messages in his time so really
at the end of the day like the
fundamental thing that Elm is sort of
all about here is guarantees about you
know what what your program can do like
the compiler checks everything it's not
just that it's like oh well you owe this
and this thing checked out and we
haven't any type here that's just sort
of an escape hatch doesn't really have
that it just yes it's gonna check
absolutely everything there's also no
mutations this is another thing that
makes it sort of easier to enforce these
guarantees Elm is designed everything is
immutable our whole quarter million
lines of code base there's not a single
mutation in there you just can't do it
Alan doesn't have syntax for mutations
also there's no side effects elmo's also
full of pure functions it's every Ellen
you write has to be pure and again the
compiler and the the library design just
guarantees that it's pretty sweet you
might be wondering okay but how do you
possibly build user interfaces in that
way like no side effects
how do you do stuff without side effects
no mutation how do you change state
without mutation and the answer is this
thing called the Elm architecture so Elm
architecture basically begins with a
view function it's gonna give you a
quick like 101 of how that works and a
view function is you give it some
arguments and it returns some virtual
Dom so a virtual DOM is basically a
description of how you want the Dom
which is to say that the webpage to look
so give it some arguments and it says
I'm just going to return how I want the
page to look so the Elm architecture
is basically taking all of these
ingredients on three ingredients and
sending them to the L runtime which is
basically what the LM compiler spits out
on the other side and sort of uses to
process all this stuff and make your
application work so you start with this
thing called the model and the model is
basically a description of your entire
application state it's one immutable
value that represents every single thing
that's going on in your application and
you pass that or rather the L runtime
passes that to your view function so it
receives the model and then returns some
virtual Dom because that's its whole job
so it's a pure function that takes model
and returns virtual Dom and then
basically the runtime then says okay
when I get some user interactions I'm
going to send messages to a function
called update those messages by the way
we just created a couple of those in our
favorited articles example the messages
are again just immutable values we
define them using type we get missing
patterns if we don't handle all of them
those get sent sorry update gets passed
the model the current model as well as
that message and then it looks at that
and says okay
what am I gonna do with this message and
the message will say something like oh
the user clicked on the favorited
articles tab or the user clicked on this
button or that button or something else
happened it says okay based on that I'm
gonna return a new model that's a new
description of our application state
that gets passed the view view creates a
new virtual DOM and then the whole cycle
begins all over again so again this is a
very 101 kind of like high-level
overview I encourage you to take a
deeper look at it but fundamentally this
is all there is to setting up
interactive applications in Elm and our
whole code base is built on this whole
thing one of the cool things about that
message is that it's a it's subject to
these same sort of making things
impossible to forget pattern matching
rules that we saw in the live coding so
if I have like click dismiss arrows
clicked follow clicked unfollow click
tab feed page all those different things
I can't forget to handle any of those
interactions if I introduce a new one of
these and I render it on the page I
cannot forget to wire it up to my logic
that won't compile if I forget likewise
I also can't put it in there and then
make it so I've just defined some logic
here without defining what shape it has
can't do that either so basically it's
like this is a complete list of possible
user actions and I know that it's
complete because any other user action I
could define would require adding
something to this list
sort of a nice hidden benefit to this of
one of my co-workers commented on is
when you come into a new Elm codebase
you're looking at a new page you're like
okay what what can the user do on this
page you just like oh that's that's what
they can do that's right there it's just
this one nice list there's a nice little
side effect of the way things are
organized in Elm L also has its own
ecosystem so there's no chance that we
would have this much like running in
production without crashing if we were
doing tons of stuff with JavaScript
libraries but we're not because Elm has
its own package ecosystem everything in
the Elm pocket ecosystem is built on top
of these set of primitives with all of
these guarantees it all works that way
so it's got its own separate package
manager
everything installs very quickly
everything compiles very quickly all of
the things on the package manager if you
want to publish it it has to have
already compiled that's a successfully
compile it also just make sure that
everything in the ecosystem maintains
all of these Elm guarantees like Elm can
do Interop with JavaScript but it's in
this very restricted way and packages
are not allowed to do it so your
application can interrupt with any
third-party JavaScript libraries you
want but the whole elm package ecosystem
is all Elm code and finally semantic
versioning is actually enforced so what
that means is if I publish a library as
version 1.2 and then I'm like okay I'm
gonna like delete a function and like
publish that as 1.1 it's like no you
deleted something that's a breaking
change you have to bump the major
version number and that's enforced
across every single package in the
entire ecosystem like they cannot
publish without bumping the major
version number if you make a breaking
change it's really really nice makes
things a lot easier to upgrade we also
saw these like super fast builds again
that's something that just really really
never gets old
and the last thing that's kind of cool
about this is that it turns out the
overhead on this is like negative like
you would think okay we're doing all
this extra stuff for like compiling to
JavaScript we got this runtime so surely
we would end up with like bigger
applications but actually it's the
opposite so this is the different real
world applications like the BJS one the
angular react one in the Elm one they're
all the same spec they're all this doing
the same front-end they have the same
logic same Styles same back-end the only
difference is what front-end technology
was used to build them and it turns out
that the compiled asset size which is
something relevant if you've got users
on mobile and your care about the
initial page
time the Elm one is just like by far the
smallest so it turns out that just
because it's this totally different
paradigm you're able to express things
differently and also a lot of
optimizations that the compiler does
that are not necessarily safe to do when
you don't have pure functions everywhere
and things like that these have some
really really practical benefits it's
not just like oh well this is an
ergonomics thing only it's like no it's
organ onyx and performance so tiny asset
bundles are like another thing that
people like about Elm oh it's just fun
I guess this I love programming l-like
there's a lot of joy the Elm community
is around like just bang and stuff out
and making stuff work it's just like
it's sort of a cheerful like happy group
of people throw some resources if you're
interested in learning more about Elm
I always recommend starting with the
official guide this is just on the Elm
website if you go to Elm Lang org and
walk through the guide it's really
well-written it's really complete it's
really nice there's also the Elm slack I
always recommend people go here
especially the beginners channel which
is like the default channel you start in
the people there are just like
unbelievably helpful to the point where
I'm like I I just don't even know what
to say about how they spend their time
because most of what they seem to do is
just helping people out on this slack
and well I just think we're incredibly
lucky to have them in our community
because they're they're so unbelievably
helpful last of all I have to mention
that I'm a the course on front-end
masters if you're a front-end masters
subscriber also element action I'm
writing a book for Manning
it's an early access so if you want you
can read the first seven chapters which
are out right now planning to target ten
chapters or depending on when you're
hearing this if you're watching it at
home maybe it's already out so have a
look at that too there's also the Elm
town podcast which has lots of like nice
interviews it's a kind of a cool way to
to keep up with what's going on in the
community that's the URL for it and
finally meet ups there's meetups all
over the world like I said Elm
programmers tend to be a pretty friendly
Bunch pretty welcoming beginners that's
sort of a cultural community value so I
would encourage you to take a look in
your nearby area and see if there's a
meet-up okay so to sum up we talked
about front-end code bases are growing
this is a trend that's shows no sign of
reversing it's just over time they've
gotten more and more complex in some
cases to the point where with event
sourcing they're the entirety of your
logic they're just getting bigger and
bigger more business
logic less as a percentage layout and
visual stuff
certainly more complexity we need more
and more tools to manage this complexity
and just more and more code to write so
how we spend our time is sort of
evolving as front-end developers this is
this is sort of inevitable and it's it's
making things sort of get harder and I
would say that new tools ought to
challenge our assumptions about like
what it means to be a front-end
developer and like how we spend our time
as a front-end developer and what
percentage of our time even should be
spent in the browser even though that's
the medium that we're targeting so yeah
I mean productivity and flow State why
shouldn't they be different now that we
have different requirements and doing
the job is fundamentally different than
it used to be so with the help of modern
tools like Elam it's entirely possible
we could even be building you eyes
faster in the dark thanks very much
so we have some time for questions but
I'll let but don't wanna keep everybody
captive so I will just do those offstage
so just if you'd like to have asked a
question just stop on by thanks very
much